[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous est il déjà arrivé de ne pas oser
parler d'un symptôme à votre médecin
parce que vous aviez peur d'être jugé ou
parce que vous n'étiez pas à l'aise à
l'idée de partager quelque chose d'un
team avec un tiers est ce qu à la place
vous avez posé la question à un moteur
de recherche est fouillé dans les
ressources d'internet pour poser vous
même un diagnostic vous faites confiance
à internet pour vous donner des
informations
pourtant vous ne connaissez pas la ou
les personnes qui ont rédigé les pages
web que vous consultez j'ai parlé de
l'histoire de madeleine madeleine c'est
une jeune femme active quarantenaire qui
mène une vie bien remplie entre sa
famille et ses passions et son travail
depuis quelques temps madeleine ressent
de la fatigue et de l'anxiété
c'est une période difficile pour elle au
travail en ce moment c'est bientôt le
lancement d'un projet sur lequel elle
travaille depuis plusieurs mois
ce matin la madeleine se lève avec des
nausées et au fur et à mesure que la
journée avance elle ressent des
difficultés à respirer sur son téléphone
madeleine un chat bottes médical le chat
box vous savez c'est cette fenêtre qui
apparaît quand vous naviguez sur
internet et qui vous demande si vous
avez besoin d aide
vous pouvez interagir avec le 7 bat
médicale sur le téléphone de madeleine
c'est un vrai partenaire de sa santé au
quotidien
elle utilise pour diagnostiquer les
petits maux de l'hiver où les bobos de
l'été
c'est un vrai partenaire de sa santé
madeleine décide donc de faire appel au
tchad bottes médical pour comprendre sa
baisse de régime
ok sentais mes symptômes fatigue nausées
anxiété difficultés à respirer ce jour
là le shabbat detec dans la voix de
madeleine sont une insuffisance
respiratoire
et non sans délai une prise en charge
immédiate aux urgences pour des examens
complémentaires
une ambulance a été automatiquement
appelé et se rend au domicile de
madeleine en attendant le chat de bottes
et de madeleine à se relaxer et lui
explique comment vont se dérouler son
parcours dessous arrivée à l'hôpital
madeleine passer un électrocardiogramme
et un bilan biologique
elle est accompagnée par une infirmière
mais ne croise aucun médecin c'est le
robot diagnostic de l'hôpital qui
analysent ces examens
c'est lui qui pose le diagnostic et qui
lui prescrit un cocktail de quatre
médicaments pour traiter ces symptômes
et éviter tout risque de récidive
alors je suis pas médecin je suis
ingénieur consultant dans le domaine de
l'intelligence artificielle pour la
santé et je dois vous avouer que pour
créer cette histoire et la rendre
cohérente
j'ai fait des recherches sur internet
sur des symptômes et leur prise en
charge
vous pensez que cette histoire c'est de
la science fiction
au royaume uni une start-up développe un
chat bottes médical qui analyse vos
symptômes médicaux sur votre téléphone
au danemark la hotline des urgences
détecte automatiquement dans la voix des
personnes qui appellent leur détresse
pulmonaire afin d'accélérer leur prise
en charge
aux etats unis une application détecte à
partir d'une image de l'oeil près d'une
cinquantaine de maladies avec de
meilleures performances que les médecins
en france une application prédit à
partir des caractéristiques des
patientes lesquels seront sujettes à des
douleurs après une opération du cancer
du sein
il me serait impossible de citer tous
les exemples toutes ces applications
fonctionnent avec des technologies on
l'appelle intelligence artificielle ou i
elle vise à reproduire la compréhension
que l'on a de l'intelligence humaine
ces applications doivent d'abord être
entraînés
sur des ensembles de données sur pour
répondre à une question précise
il faut donc créer des bases de données
en amont pour pouvoir les entraîner par
exemple si on veut développer une
application qui analyse les grains de
beauté
il faut au préalable recueillir des
photos de grains de beauté pour lesquels
on connaît avec certitude si ce sont des
mélanomes ou s'ils sont bénins
l'algorithme est ensuite entraîné sur
ces données
et après un certain temps il sera
capable de dire si on lui présente une
nouvelle photo de grains de beauté si
c'est un mélanome ou pas vous l'avez
compris les applications de
l'intelligence artificielle dans la
santé permettent de prédire de prescrire
de diagnostiquer ou encore de fluidifier
la prise en charge des soins
ce sont des outils à destination des
médecins il faut gagner un temps
précieux aux médecins sur des tâches
chronophages ou sans valeur ajoutée
parfois ils permettent d'analyser les
données avec de meilleurs résultats que
les médecins doit-on s'attendre à ce que
l'intelligence artificielle remplacent
les médecins l'évolution des métiers de
la médecine ne date pas d'hier
les médecins se sont toujours doté
d'outils supplémentaires pour avoir
tenir des données pour pouvoir poser
leurs diagnostics ou organiser les soins
autrefois pour être cardiologue il
fallait avoir l'oreille absolue
l'oreille absolue c'est cette aptitude à
reconnaître une note de musique sans
référence auditive préalable aujourd'hui
tout le monde peut être cardiologue
grâce à l'invention du stéthoscope les
applications d'intelligence artificielle
sont donc des nouveaux outils à
destination du médecin comme le sont le
stéthoscope où les rayons x ou les
analyses biologiques
actuellement aucune technique
d'intelligence artificielle n'est
capable d'imiter le raisonnement du
médecin durant son parcours à l'hôpital
madeleine n'avait rencontré aucun
médecin et c'était le robot diagnostic
de l'hôpital qui avait posé un
diagnostic est prescrit son traitement
c'est là l'unique aspect science fiction
de mon histoire et cette histoire elle a
commencé avec les symptômes de madeleine
qui parmi vous a su diagnostiquer ce
qu'elle avait nausées fatigue anxiété
difficultés à respirer qui a trouvé que
madeleine était en train de faire un
infarctus
vous pouvez lever la main visiblement
personne fatigue anxiété nausées
difficultés à respirer
ce sont les symptômes qui annonce un
infarctus chez les femmes en france
d'après le ministère de la santé la
première cause de mortalité chez les
hommes c'est le cancer est la première
cause chez les femmes ce sont les
maladies cardiovasculaires il n'est pas
certain que madeleine aurait pensé
d'elle-même à aller consulter les
urgences si son chat bottes médical ne
lui avaient pas préconisé peut-être
aurait-elle juste pensé qu'elle faisait
un peu de surmenage dans l'imaginaire
collectif ce sont les hommes qui font
des infarctus et on en connaît tous les
symptômes une douleur oppressante dans
la poitrine et ou une douleur il irradie
le bras ce préjugé entraîne une prise en
charge plus tardive des femmes et ce qui
augmente par conséquent leur mortalité
le chat vote médical de madeleine a donc
su déjouer les préjugés de jambe et lui
a probablement évité une fin tragique
en vérité c'est pas tout à fait finie
pour madeleine en rentrant de l'hôpital
elle pensait être sorti d'affaires le
robot diagnostic l'avait prescrit un
cocktail de quatre médicaments pour
éviter tout risque de récidive de
l'infarctus
mais quelques semaines plus tard
madeleine ressent à nouveau les mêmes
symptômes
comment est ce possible madeleine est
d'origine asiatique et une petite partie
de son patrimoine génétique empêche un
des quatre médicaments de fonctionner
correctement
le séquençage de l'adn de madeleine
figuré bien dans son dossier médical
l'information était là mais cette
information n'était pas prise en compte
par l'algorithme médias du robot d
urgence
rappelez-vous les algorithmes soit à m
entraîner à répondre à une question
précise à partir de bases de données
si les données d'entraînement ne
comprennent pas un paramètre par exemple
les données génétiques alors
l'algorithme ne peut pas s'entraîner à
le prendre en compte et là j'aimerais
attirer votre attention sur ce problème
qui me semble fondamental en ia pour la
santé qui est la représentativité des
données
si on veut développer une application
qui analyse les grains de beauté etc on
les entraîne sur des photos sur peau
claire l'algorithme ne sera inutilisable
sur peau foncée ce genre de
considérations vous semblez vie dont je
vous ai indiqué que la première cause de
mortalité chez les femmes ce sont les
maladies cardiovasculaires or seulement
33 % des participants au protocole de
recherche sur les maladies
cardiovasculaires sont les femmes est-ce
que vous pensez que les données seront
représentatives alors la question
fondamentale devient comment rendre la
médecine plus inclusive c'est à dire
comment prendre en compte tous les
profils potentiel des passions l'ia est
pour moi une occasion unique de réduire
les biais de genre dans la société
pour peu qu'on fasse attention à la
représentativité des données pour sortir
définitivement madeleine d'affaires il a
fallu qu'un médecin de l'hôpital analyse
son dossier et identifient la cause de
son intolérance à l'un des quatre
médicaments
il a pas lié aux limites de lia et a su
prescrire un nouveau traitement anti
récidive personnalisés
pour madeleine depuis madeleine et
retourner à ses occupations
elle se porte bien et vous aimeriez vous
comme madeleine disposer d'un chat bonne
médical sur votre téléphone pour vous
soigner vous consultez déjà des
informations médicales sur internet pour
le pire comme pour le meilleur et sur
internet
il y à des informations qui sont plus
fier
bhl que d'autres davantage dans le monde
médical c'est que les outils utilisés
qu'on appelle dispositifs médicaux sont
régulés il ne suffit pas de développer
un nouveau dispositif pour qu'ils
puissent être utilisés il faut qu'il
soit homologué et que un protocole
d'utilisation soient définies par
exemple sur un scanner la qualité des
données d du paramétrage est très
importante pour obtenir des images de
qualité et une mauvaise calibration peut
entraîner des erreurs médicales
la calibration et donc régulièrement
contrôlés et il faut suivre un protocole
de façon rigoureuse lorsqu'on acquiert
une nouvelle image
les outils d'intelligence artificielle
sont donc des nouveaux dispositifs
médicaux à disposition des médecins
comme tout nouveau dispositif ils
doivent être régulés que ce soit dans
leur usage dans quel cadre
avec quel supervision du corps médical
que dans la façon qu'ils ont été conçus
c'est à dire quelles sont les données
qui ont servi à entraîner les
algorithmes et ce pour s'assurer que
tous les profils des patients seront
inclus le cadre réglementaire de l'ia
dans la santé restent encore à définir
il me semble donc indispensable que
chaque citoyen en comprenne les enjeux
et participe au débat demain ne seront
pas tous médecins
grâce à l'intelligence artificielle mais
nous devons veiller à ce que les
opportunités offertes par ce
bouleversement technologique permettent
de rendre la médecine plus inclusive
pour tous et toutes
je vous remercie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]